Let's go next to our caller from the 6 0 2
area code who's calling today from 6:00.
So to.
Close to me.
Yes, it is.
Oh, boy, there's a Jameson.
Phenix, let me know if you can hear me.
Yes, I can.
You know, James, the weirdest thing is going
on in between ice.
When.
Yeah.
And when you spoke, I could have sworn I heard
a woman's voice.
It's almost like there are lines crossed.
That's weird.
Yeah, because I'm totally alone in this room
right now as it should be.
I believe there is no woman anyway.
Anyway, my my quest.
Having us dropped out.
Do you think that the progressive movement
has sort of missed its moment in the United
States of having a big limelight?
Or do you think we're going to have to not
wait another 30, 40 years for another Bernie
Sanders to build up and kind of have a huge
record behind him?
Listen, here's the reality.
Here we go.
I don't think I either.
I'm not worried about that.
I don't think that's going to be the case.
Remember, Bernie Sanders moved into the forefront.
A lot of ideas that are now arguably mainstream
or mainstream for a large majority of the
United States.
And that's absolutely fantastic.
But he we have not yet gotten to turning that
slate of ideas into accomplishments.
Is it going to happen under a Joe Biden presidency?
No, it's not.
But could some elements maybe be made a reality?
I am hopeful.
And that's where it comes down to.
You know, if we want the next four years to
be as progressive as possible, now that Bernie's
out and it's Biden versus Trump, the best
shot we have is to have a stake in the Biden
presidency by all getting the hell out and
voting and pressuring Biden and the House
and the Senate.
If Biden is lucky enough to become president
of the United States to do as much as possible
of a truly progressive agenda.
And I know that it's underwhelming, but it's
already host.
But if we don't do that, then it's just trump
another four years and we go in the completely
wrong direction.
You understand what I'm saying, my friend?
Yeah.
Hey, I'm very listening.
I know.
Do you think Joe Biden would even listen?
Because I get today.
I just don't think Joe Biden would listen
as if I can do anything to change that.
As one man.
I think that he would listen if the right
people are talking to him.
We've seen him make some modification begin
to some of his financial policy based on Elizabeth
Warren's ideas.
I would hope now that Bernie is out that maybe
Joe Biden is going to listen to Bernie and
adopt something from Bernie's platform.
I'm hopeful.
And you know what?
It might not happen, but it's definitely not
happening under Donald Trump.
That's for sure.
All right.
Nice.
I couldn't hear most of you, but I'll see
it on the show later.
Keep up the good work, Dave Anderson and other
different things.
All right.
Very good.
I'm going to take a quick break.
I'm going to reset the phone system.
If you're holding, don't hang up.
If the system hangs up on you, please call
back.
We're going to see.
I think the tubes are very full right now.
So we're going to go to a quick break.
Don't hang up.
But if I accidentally knock you off line,
please call right back.